the laws of war prohibit the intentional
killing of civilians and the
disproportionate killing that's to say
killing that is not necessary to achieve
um a an important military
objective and and the reason the laws of
war are permissive in that way is
because you can't fight a war
successfully without risking civilian
casualties often and certainly during
the second world war the Allies um uh
cause Grievous harm to civilians not
because they wanted it not because they
intended it uh but because there was no
other way of fighting the Nazis
effectively so you're saying if you
think that war needs to happen then
civilians sometimes need to die I I'm
I'm afraid so not not in every case but
but but usually that that is the case um
I mean if you're a pacifist then of
course no casualties military or or
non-military are are acceptable morally
if you're not a pacifist um then uh
you're going to have to accept there
will be a lot of tragic deaths